when you mismatch people and programs
it's going to be bad for everybody but
if people go toward what they are suited
for what they show an aptitude for what
will lead them to flourish everybody is
going to be better off and by the way if
you go into an apprenticeship program if
you start working at 18 you're one
you're going to learn a lot more hard
skills almost certainly than people who
go to college but it's not like that
means you won't ever have a liberal
education you can get your liberal
education while you're doing the
apprenticeship program you can read you
can take courses you can join reading
groups and study groups plenty of that
happens and that used to happen a lot
more in America when there was a richer
and more diverse Civil Life before heavy
hand of the total State came in and just
tried to homogenize everybody you can do
that that can be a wonderful thing